and looking to add to it these final
seconds of the third quarter
Dion driving on white and finishing
[Music]
two on the shot clock for the waiters
Kendrick Mother's of the gift for Miami
first time we see the young man before
me Chicago heroes etiquette Chris Silva
played eight games for the Dallas
Mavericks last year and then 41 games
for their G league team the Texas
Legends nice drive to school by dion
Waiters plus the phone gets marvin
williams at 6:10 guarding MCS got the
quickness advantage strong left to right
crossover then gets to that reverse side
where Marvin can't hey Emma Fox Sports
up group and of course heat nation we're
happy to have you at Tech and I heard
he's get the heat before the regular
season begins the dion Waiters having a
nice first half child leaders thought
about the triple bow maneuvers through
the defense finds kendrick none well
done by the end waiters waiters can
bring other than the scoring third
assist saw the whole thing from the top
straightaway went right over the top of
the defense with the pass was years
career high and assists through his
first three what blocked by
those years career-high desist was 10
and he had nine against Boston in the
preseason opener without a turnover with
his most impressive
dion Waiters knocking it down was range
forcing them the stretch approaching
three minutes left in the second quarter
in another the full pass by waiters he
just snapped the pass to the wide open
Duncan Robinson hero off the shot fake
waiters wide open for three
it's tense terrific first and
performance dion Waiters put on the show
get the done inside off the dribble how
about outside as well from three give
yourself a pat do
agrestic get some minutes and the
preseason the heat predicted this would
happen and it has yeah I mean after the
bone bruise to the knee and the World
Championship and great to see Kelly back
he's had three solid practices we were
told from this is dion Waiters with a
nice ball fake drive and look at the way
he finishes here going up and up
dion against the [ __ ] taller cutter
williams ended up Bank it in anyway so
dion Waiters three shots to school i
gave you some time now have you figured
out a Doc Rivers calm oh yes very easy
by the way I could do this all night
players eight by Tyler hero to lead the
team Kawhi Leonard and sham it and green
with he's not sigh we know he's very
confident he can knock down three
Kennedy on sends it up from the baseline
and Ferries Miami trying to cutter that
deficit trailing by 13 with Kawhi
Leonard on the bench laners
dion Waiters at his twenty20 debut is
right here moving without the basketball
shot ready every single time on me
Williams against waiters right there
about dion Waiters not didn't block the
shot one time he blocked it twice and
not only that he was available he made
himself available to make the big time
shot just wonderful multiple efforts
right here I mean talk about a guy
looking to seize the moment and seize an
opportunity right there that's knowing
your personnel knowing when Lou goes
left he wants that pull-up it was just
very good defense and a nice pass right
there by bam competetive on the second
quarter change captain with a pretty
black against Terrence Ross
[Applause]
like Derrick Jones jr. and Dion Waiters
helping Miami off the bench not with
scores with a couple of promises and
there's a triple for me on Dion Waiters
who has a way of lighting up the room
when he walks him waiters those delay
autumn shot clock at 8 waiters for three
yes sir dion Waiters offensively in that
first quarter six made threes matches a
season-high for Boston in the first
quarter this year and coming out of the
quarter break loose start shooting the
ball for Boston waiters will oblige and
waiters has it cook it early one in the
corner